- Hi, Bubbles.
- Well, say hello to Bubbles and Joe.
- Hi, Bubbles. And hello, sir.
- Hello.
- I would not touch Bubbles, however.
Or, maybe don't touch Joe
'cause Bubbles might get mad.
But, not that you were
gonna do that anyway
'cause that'd be a weird thing.
- I want to.
- (Kelly laughing) Yeah, that'd be weird.
But, how did you two first meet?
- Oh, my gosh. So, we came up in comedy
at the Upright Citizens Brigade theater
and I met Danielle, in a dark theater
where she had her boyfriend
pinned up against the wall,
making out with him for about ten minutes.
- Yes.
- And I was like, "This is disturbing".
I thought they met that night.
They'd been together for ten years.
- (Kelly laughing) The
fire is still alive.
- Yes.
- The fire is still alive
and it was an awkward way to meet someone.
- Yeah, and that man
has become my husband,
so, take a tip, ladies.
(audience cheering)
- Yeah. Keep the fire alive.
- Keep the fire going.
- How do you feel about PDA, Joe?
- PDA?
- PDA. You know, Public
Display of Affection.
That kind of...
- Are you asking me if
I made out with my wife
backstage at the Upright
Citizens Brigade theater?
- (crowd laughs) That's
what we're asking, Joe.
- Yeah, all the time.
- That was specific, but...
- What about you and Bubbles?
(Kelly laughing)
- This is the baby.
This is my baby, that would be disgusting.
- (Danielle laughing)
That would be disgusting.
So, wait, you're both married now.
So, do your husbands do anything in public
that drive you crazy?
- (sighs) Yes.
- [Kelly] I'm sure and
I'm sure you do something
that drives him crazy, too.
- I don't think so.
- I'm perfect.
- (Kelly laughing) Okay.
- I don't think I do.
- I think I'm a catch.
But for him, personally,
he does this thing that
really frustrates me.
Which is, he will not
share a dessert with me.
So, when we order dessert-
Yeah. See, that's our dessert.
He won't share her with me.
(Danielle laughing)
No, he won't share it.
So, I would like us to
order something together
and he's like, "Get your own stuff"
like, "Don't come over here."
- Wow.
- Yeah.
- People are very upset.
- Yes, isn't that so rude?
And I'm like, "Look, I
don't want to look like
I would indulge in such disgustingness.
But when you get yours,
I would like half of it,
and maybe all of it."
(audience laughing)
- What was your husband's name again?
- His name is Matt Besser.
- Matt. Continue to make
her get her own dessert.
(guests and audience
laughing and cheering)
- I'm right there with you.
- Because here's the thing,
literally, my drummer just
chased me around a game.
We were at the game and I
had a lovely piece of pie
that I had on my plate, for me.
- For you. Get your own!
- This, dude, is coming
in here with his fork,
trying to get my-
I was like "No, bro,
it's never gonna happen,
I'm never going to share my-"
There is a whole pie over there.
They have more desserts at the restaurant.
Order yours.
- When I go to the
movies, I turn to friends
and say "I will literally
buy you whatever you want,
don't come grabbing one
skittle, one red vine,
I don't care if you just
want one, it's mine."
(audience cheering)
And I like you as a friend.
- It's more so like
when you're eating too,
it's like the saliva on your fork
and it's going back in my pie.
It's just deeper, right? It's deeper.
(audience laughing)
- I don't know if saliva is a problem
with her and her husband.
- No, we're fine.
(everyone laughing)
- Sounds like that's not the issue.
- No.
- No, that gets everywhere.
- Okay, okay.
So, I'm with Matt.
I stand with Matt on this one.
- As do I.
- [Kelly] So, Casey, you
shared a meal you made
for your kids. So, let's see this.
- Yeah, I'm a beautiful chef.
- [Kelly] Okay.
(Kelly and audience laughing)
- Oh my God, that legit looks
like what I had after school
when my mom wasn't home
and I was alone in an apartment.
- [Casey] Yeah, look,
everything I make is with love
and that, actually, was
a pretty big meal for me.
I whipped it up from scratch
and I just have a way in the kitchen
And honestly, I was proud of that.
- [Kelly] You got crazy.
You got creative.
- I got crazy. Yeah.
- Was it a special request?
- [Casey] It was a
special night, you know.
(Kelly laughing)
No, my son is so picky.
Honestly, if we get him to eat a hotdog,
we feel as though he has gotten vegetables
and my friend's like "it's just a hotdog",
and I'm like "he did so well today."
- My son is the same,
He literally only eats beige.
- [Casey] Yeah!
- It's a thing, I can't
get him to... yeah.
- But I'm sure you cook,
I mean I'm also not
presenting options that,
as you see, are so appetizing.
- No, I do not cook.
I, literally, after
winning Idol 20 years ago,
my people are like "what do you
want to do with your money?"
I go, "I want to make enough money
where someone makes me food."
(crowd laughing)
- That's the trick.
- That's exactly right.
- That's it.
- That's what I need to
do, I need to win Idol.
- That's where I'm spending my money.
- Win Idol and get money. Okay.
- Just in case you're like
"I wonder what she does
with her money, "on chefs".
Because it's not that I'm not good
I don't enjoy it, I don't enjoy cooking.
- Neither do I, I don't want
to feel bad about that anymore.
- I know. Because I have boobs,
doesn't mean I automatically
love to hold a skillet.
So like, yeah.
(everyone cheering)
Now, I don't mind cooking,
though, if you're in the kitchen
with a bunch of people
and you're all helping.
Do you do that? Do you like cooking?
- No.
- [Kelly] No, me neither. Okay.
- No. No.
- Did you do the same thing?
"I just want to make
enough to have someone..."
- That was it. Well, the first big check
was a bed that my feet don't
hang off of the end on;
a couch, same thing.
and then, somebody to cook food for me.
- Yeah. It's amazing.
- 'Cause, my wife, she, you know.
- [Kelly] She loves to cook?
- She does not. No. (crowd laughing)
- I thought you were going the other way.
- [Kelly] We all have our
talents. We all have our talents.
That is not mine either.
Okay, so let's talk about the podcast.
'Cause I just wanna say
it for a third time,
"Bitch Sesh" on my show.
So, it grew out of your love
for the Real Housewives, right?
- Yes.
- Okay, so what was this conversation
getting it started like?
- I'll tell you, we, you know,
we've been best friends forever.
We love the Real Housewives.
We love to hate them.
We hate to love them. We
love these gorgeous monsters.
(everyone laughing)
And we are comedians
and so, it's all comedy
and it's done with a
certain amount of love,
and we just love discussing them.
- And it's something you can talk about,
where I'll be on a plane with someone,
and see that they're
watching Real Housewives
and we can hate and love someone
and everyone still ends up
friends at the end. You know?
- Yeah.
It's like our Superbowl, it's our sports.
(Kelly laughing)
- It's our politics.
- Yeah, it's our Oscars.
- Yes, it's everything
for us. It's something...
- And these women, I think you'll agree,
are the great comedians of
our time, I am telling you.
(Kelly laughing)
These women are wild.
- Again, speaking as
professional comedians,
I'm always like, "I'm out of work
because these women are funnier
than anything I can write
in my life".
- Well, speaking of how
amazing we are at cooking,
we're gonna be cooking next.
You can hear...
(everyone laughing)
So, it's gonna go-
- Here I go.
- Swimmingly well.
Casey and Danielle on Bitch
Sesh, 4th time there, yep,
wherever you get your podcasts
and don't miss their special live stream,
"Bitch Sesh, live from home"
(Kelly laughing) Thanks, mom. sorry.
6th annual Halloween Spooktacular.
Spooktacular, I don't
know how you say that,
How do you say Spooktacular?
- Spooktacular, and
Andy Cohen is our guest.
- Oh, I love Andy.
- (audience cheering) Yes.
- [Kelly] Oh, that's fun.
Alright, and that's on November 3rd
and tickets are online now,
So, go do that.
And one of our favorite
chefs, I love Stephanie Izard,
is cooking with us, for us, next.
Because we all need the help.